[Music]
this may sound crazy but one of the
assignments in this course is for you to
figure out how to put a cat on Mars why
do we do this because it's a great
hypothetical example that makes you
think about the strategy for a complex
project and then plan through all of the
processes you need to have in place for
successful strategy execution
I'm Eric Rosenbach Harvard professor and
former Pentagon chief of staff and
assistant secretary of defense for
Homeland defense and Global Security
during my time working as chief of staff
at the largest organization in the world
I worked on and witnessed very complex
issues of strategy execution on a near
daily basis
now I want to try and help others
improve their ability to have impact in
this course I will lead you through real
life public sector challenges to
illustrate how purposely developed
public strategies lead to long-term
adoption and success one of the great
things about this course is that you're
going to learn directly from individuals
who have worked on executing complex
strategies in the real world for example
Juliet Cayenne worked as the assistant
Secretary of Homeland Security Ani Blair
is currently the executive director of
ACLU Texas and you'll even hear from Ash
Carter the former Secretary of Defense
when I teach this class here at the
Kennedy School my students are really
excited to learn about how you get
things done it's very rare that there's
a course on strategy execution and
that's what it's all about they want to
have impact in the world and make a
difference and this class helps them
learn the tools to do that
[Music]